do I look tired good up all night but I
finally beat Zelda The Legend of Zelda
Skyward Sword a Legend of Zelda Skyward
Sword has a lot to live up to there are
a lot of Zelda games out there and
everyone likes all of them even the side
scroller one which was absurdly hard
that games dead let me tell you that one
Legend of Zelda Skyward Sword link Zelda
all then they live up in a place called
sky lock just like you know floating
pieces of land like on Avatar yeah and
they live up there you know life is good
they fly around on their Birds which is
really fun to do in the game seriously
you fly around on this bird you could
like dive-bomb the bird you can jump off
the bird then do like you know the Iron
Man you know when he just goes vertical
and just go straight down he picks up
g-force you call your bird back you hop
back on him yeah I can do this for hours
you gotten a horse named Epona but you
do have a bird named bird and of course
this evil is coming back and now Zelda
and link they have to fulfill their
destinies and now we have our Legend of
Zelda Skyward Sword game so how is the
game well we'll talk about the controls
first the controls in this game are
actually really cool you need the Wii
MotionPlus controller you move this
controller around you see link like just
pivot his sword exactly how your
controller is that's awesome I was like
that is right there man and some enemies
out there they'll block like this so you
can only slash them that way I really
like that that's some swordplay right
there but is it perfect no it's not
perfect sometimes man I was slashing
sideways I'm like Clank why aren't you
hitting him Clank please hit him I still
don't know why it wasn't just I was
hitting the words should go so yeah you
run into those kind of scenarios there's
just one enemy in this game dude of all
the Zelda games that I've played this
enemy in here is my least favorite I
hate him more than anything he looks
like the head of a totem pole he just
kind of hops around you have to like hit
two crystals on him when he can slash
the other you have to stab and I was
starving and it was telling me I wasn't
stabbing and after you you know you
screw up the stab when he does a slash
when you should have been doing a stab
the thing stomps on you like a total
douchebag yeah
I hate him because in the end I end up
looking like this
these other guys I hate that there's
these lizards that have like armor on
one side for some messed-up reason they
were so hard to hit it is like Clank and
then the uppercut you end taht they
taunt after they uppercut you and
totally floor you they'll bounce back
and it'll be like that really look like
that I'm not messing with you in which
case I get really frustrated and I end
up being like just rude it's not the
brightest moment in my life but it
happened other than that the controls
are actually really good and it actually
you know when it kind of gets off-center
you can just Center it with the down
button you're like okay now I'm back to
Center that's awesome some games don't
have that function I'm surprised there's
not more that dude ending classic Legend
of Zelda styles these dungeons are
absurdly hard some puzzles you're like I
solved that that's awesome that's how it
should be ice it was hard and I solved
it that's why I'm smart others you just
kind of feel like Oh guys you just can't
figure it out but you eventually do and
all is right in the world of Zelda now
I'll say this and I'm not quite sure
what it is but Zelda games for me are
slow until you get past the first
dungeon I don't know what it is about
that first dungeon it's like sitting in
traffic while waiting to go to a really
sweet concert you're sitting there in
the traffic or on the first dungeon
you're just like come on just get
already but then you get there and it's
awesome you walk out of the concert
you're like I'm not even thinking about
the traffic so much more has happened
since the traffic or the first dungeon
metaphorically speaking I'm not even
thinking about it it has been so awesome
since then so as someone who really
likes a good character driven story I
have to give this game all sorts of
props they did a really good job with
the characters in this game I just
remember like Twilight Princess Zelda
and link really didn't have anything
going on whatsoever she was just kind of
a chick and then she was gone and then
you're on your adventure in this one
Lincoln Zelda have a relationship and
then throughout the adventure you see
them grow and I really like that they do
a good job at that you know these two
are young they just want to have their
life but their destiny is huge and it's
bigger than whatever relationship they
might have and he steps up to it they do
a really good job at a point I was like
link is like Harry Potter
he's that young kid is kind of forced
into a situation but he steps up he's
like alright no you know what I guess
this is how it has to be if I'm gonna
die I'm gonna face the guy who's gonna
do it to me a couple of times dude I was
like yeast he is awesome and Zelda at
first she kind of reminded me of the
chick from tangled you know she's like
this really fun young chick by the end
she's like you know the Zelda that we
all know more stoic more
you know because that the gravity of
this situation just kind of did changed
them and the animation does a good job
of it too you actually see their facial
expressions so you know what they're
feeling at that moment other games you
know just kind of like they're like
plastic mannequin heads that blink
sometimes not in this game this game
does a good job with the animation
although it is still a standard deaf
game and I'm not griping about a
gameplay a solid game if it's like
sprites I'd be fine with it but we do
live in a high-def world and you know
when you see 480i
it's still 480 not 1080 you know lower
resolution sometimes it just kind of
pixel lights when you're in the darker
dungeons and whatnot so you kind of
notice it you know it irritates you but
you get past it you know cuz you're
really stuck on a dungeon you don't care
about the animation you just want to
solve that puzzle you can't solve in the
end I ended up playing this game for 56
hours 56 hours of a Zelda game I didn't
even find all the extra stuff I just I
found extra stuff as they came a couple
times I was like alright I'll find some
of these little you know we'll trinkets
and whatnot but all in all we're just
trying to you know beat the desert 56
hours this is the longest Delta game
I've ever played I can say The Legend of
Zelda Skyward Sword makes all other
Legend of Zelda games look like casual
gamer games so great characters a great
story a great emotional story you know
good coming-of-age story hours upon
hours of solid gameplay when I wasn't
being all like oh you've done it - The
Legend of Zelda Skyward Sword is awesome
tacular
it's like a really good Disney movie you
know back in their prime where you're
like yeah it's good for all ages but
damn it man if it doesn't hit you right
where you live a few times couple times
I was like that is one of the most
touching things I've seen in a game
another thing I liked was the music the
music was all orchestrated and sounded
awesome and some of the music and some
of the dungeons I don't remember it all
I'm not going to remember them other
music you're like that is just great
like the music when you're flying on
your bird epic and the theme and Skyward
Sword a funny thing the theme in Skyward
Sword is actually the theme in Ocarina
of Time backwards
yeah it'll blow your mind check this out
Skyward Sword theme forward and
backwards
yeah as your mind blown I know like how
do you do that how can someone take a
great song reverse it and turn it into a
great song that is genius so if you
played Skyward Sword what did you think
of it comment below let me know I'm
curious alright what did you think of
the backwards song mind balloon mine was
not gonna lie I didn't sleep for like
two days when I saw that in any case if
you like what you've seen here and you
want to see more click right here to see
more